digamos que vivo en un país donde abunda
la paz y a todos los habitantes les
encantan las matemáticas ahora es un
país donde habitan 100 millones de
personas y habrá elecciones
presidenciales con dos candidatos el
candidato y el candidato ve ahora este
es un país decisivo todos participan
aquí nadie se queda sin participar ya
sea voten por el as o por el candidato b
entonces existe un porcentaje digamos
que hay una realidad que p bueno luego
por aquí
1 - pero mejor no mejor pongo primero p
ok hay cierta realidad en esto pensemos
que p por ciento vota por ver y el resto
de las personas de mi país votan por a
digamos 1 - p por ciento vota por el
candidato a quizás ya reconozcas que
esta es una distribución de bernal y
donde por cada muestra si yo tengo dos
valores en una muestra yo puedo obtener
un valor y en esta muestra o estás
votando por alcance
o por el candidato b esos son los
valores pero es difícil lidiar con estos
valores ya que no podemos calcular la
media entre a y b porque estos son
letras no números podemos suponer lo
siguiente que la probabilidad de que una
persona vote por a es cero y la
probabilidad de que una persona vote por
el candidato b es 1 entonces usando la
distribución de bernuy lo que tenemos es
que la media para esta distribución
tenemos que la media es igual a p y la
manera para obtener esto en este caso es
bastante trivial entonces la media será
igual bueno de hecho será igual a un
valor que esta distribución no puede
tomar será igual a p ahora mi país tiene
100 millones de personas las cuales
todas son pacíficas y llenas de amor por
las matemáticas es imposible para mí ir
a cada una de ellas y decirle hey tú por
qué vas a votar me es imposible
preguntarle a todos no voy a saber
exactamente cuál es el parámetro aquí
es la media p quién es p entonces haré
un estudio al azar haré un estudio de la
población veré los datos después de ahí
obtener un estimado de quienes en
realidad p porque esto es lo que en
realidad me importa yo quiero saber
quién es p entonces vamos a estimar ap
con un estudio una muestra y vamos a ver
qué tan buena estimación es lo que haré
es un estudio al azar de 100 personas un
muestreo de 100 personas y digamos que
obtengo los siguientes resultados
digamos que 57 personas dijeron que van
a votar por el candidato a lo voy a
poner de esta otra manera voy a poner
57 57 personas votaron por el candidato
a que es equivalente a obtener 57
muestras de 0 y el resto de la población
como lo dije es un país decisivo el
resto de la población 4343 van a votar
por el candidato ve que es equivalente a
43 muestras de 1
dada esta muestra cuál es la media de mi
muestra y cuál es la varianza de mi
muestra entonces la media de mi muestra
va a ser el promedio de estos ceros y
éstos unos entonces yo tengo 57 05 43
unos por lo tanto tengo 57 por 0 más mis
43 unos entonces 43 por 1 entre el total
de muestras 100 es decir hago la suma de
todas mis muestras sobre el total de
muestras y que obtengo 57 por 0 20 y 43
por uno entre 100
es 0.43 y esa es la media de mi muestra
la media de la muestra con solamente 100
personas ahora cuál es mi varianza
muestral mi varianza de muestra es la
suma del cuadrado de las diferencias de
cualquiera de mis datos a la media
dividido por mis muestras menos 1 ahora
recuerda esta es una variante muestral y
lo que yo quiero obtener es la mejor
estimación de la varianza real de esta
distribución y para hacer esto no
dividimos entre 100 dividimos entre 100
menos 1 entonces tengo 57 lo pongo en el
color amarillo mejor este tengo lo
siguiente 57 muestras de 0 las cuales
cada una tiene distancia a la media de 0
- 0.43 cada una de esas muestras son 0
le restó 0.43 entonces está la distancia
y si la quiero la distancia al cuadrado
le pongo al cuadrado
así es como se calcula la varianza luego
más hice el muestreo de 43 veces 1
entonces pongo 1 menos la media o sea la
distancia del 1 la media al cuadrado
0.43 es la media entonces pongo un 0.43
al cuadrado ahora no voy a dividir entre
n recuerdan no voy a dividir entre 100
lo que yo quiero es la estimación
verdadera de la media de esta población
y para obtener la mejor estimación de
esto yo no voy a dividir entre 100 lo
voy a dividir entre 100 menos 1 y esto
lo expliqué hace varios vídeos ahora voy
a sacar la calculadora para obtener el
resultado de nuestra varianza muestral
entonces voy a calcular voy a abrir
paréntesis para poner a todo lo que esté
en el numerador y lo voy a dividir entre
100 menos 1 entonces pongo 57 por 0 -
punto 43 que es lo mismo que 0.43 esto
elevado al cuadrado más 43
1 - 0.43 y un 0.43 lo elevó otra vez al
cuadrado es definición y esto todo esto
en el numerador lo voy a dividir en 3 y
el menos 1 que es lo mismo que 99
entonces entre 99 es igual a punto 24 75
75 y esto entonces la varianza muestral
es igual a 0.24 75 si quiero saber cuál
es la desviación estándar de mi muestra
solamente tomo la raíz de mi varianza
muestral entonces tomó en la calculadora
la raíz de 0.24 75 que es igual a punto
43 75 esa es mi desviación estándar de
muestra y la voy a redondear mejor a 50
por qué punto 49 7 como que no entonces
punto 50 es mi desviación estándar de
muestra
observas esto y dices ah bueno tu mejor
estimación del porcentaje de las
personas que van a votar ya sea por ado
por ver es justamente esto de aquí
tenemos que la mejor estimación de la
media es que 43% de las personas van a
votar por ver el resto van a votar por
el candidato a pero una pregunta
interesante es que tan buena estimación
es esa es más llevémoslo a un nivel más
alto pensemos en un intervalo alrededor
de 43% para el cual el 95% está seguro
estamos totalmente confiados de que en
ese intervalo el 95% estamos seguros de
que en ese intervalo está la media real
cuando hacemos la media de nuestra
muestra lo que estamos es haciendo la
muestra de la distribución muestral de
nuestra media muestral entonces como
estamos haciendo la muestra de una
distribución discreta esto va a ser una
distribución discreta pero va a tener
100 posibles valores es decir esto puede
tomar 100 posibles valores lo que sea
0 y 1 ahora lo voy a dibujar como
continuo porque si no tendría que
dibujar 100 diferentes barras entonces
tendría una barra aquí y otra aquí otra
aquí y hasta hasta llegar a 100 entonces
así queda mejor sí y además la
probabilidad de que tu media muestral
fuera 1 sería muy baja será una
probabilidad muy baja tendría que
dibujar 100 barras entonces mejor dibujo
esta curva normal ahora distribución
muestras de la media muestral esto es lo
voy a poner aquí distribución muestral
de la media muestral
media muestra
muestra ahora aquí aquí hay una media
esta media
la voy a denotar por su x esto nos dice
que aquí está la media de la
distribución muestral pero sabemos por
varios vídeos anteriores que esta es la
media
esta es la media poblacional de donde
estamos haciendo el muestreo para cada
muestra y son 100 muestras entonces esto
va a ser igual a mu que va a ser igual a
p es decir mucho x
muxu x es igual a mu que es igual a p
ahora esta varianza aquí la varianza de
esta distribución la voy a poner aquí a
dibujar aquí es más mejor digo la
desviación estándar de esta distribución
la desviación estándar esta distancia la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral de la media muestral va a ser y
bueno ya lo hemos visto varias veces
será la desviación estándar de nuestra
distribución poblacional entonces esa
desviación estándar será esta distancia
de aquí luego hay una desviación
estándar asociada a esta distribución y
será esa desviación estándar dividida
entre la medida de nuestra muestra 100 y
ya vimos en varios vídeos anteriores
porque esto tiene sentido entonces vamos
a tomar aquí la raíz cuadrada de 100
esto es igual a este 4 con sombrero
sobre 10 y no sabemos quién sea ese 4
con sombrero la manera que podemos
saberlo es haciendo el estudio
de las 100 millones de personas en ese
país lo cual es prácticamente imposible
no imagínate entonces para estimar la
desviación estándar lo que vamos a usar
es la desviación estándar muestral y la
usaremos como la mejor estimación que
tenemos de nuestra desviación estándar
poblacional ahora recordemos que esta es
una estimación no podemos tener el valor
exacto con una muestra pero podemos
tener una estimación porque este es
nuestro mejor estimador para la
desviación estándar y si lo dividimos
entre 10 tendremos el mejor estimador
para la desviación estándar de nuestra
distribución muestral de la media
muestral ahora recuerda que esta es
solamente una estimación de aquí en
adelante tendrás que tomar las cosas con
un poco de escepticismo entonces esto es
aproximadamente 0.50 y ahora recuerda
cada vez que tomo aquí una muestra
diferente este número cambia no se queda
igual no es como una piedra y estancada
no es
depende de la muestra que tomemos ahora
en esta muestra tenemos 0.50 que es la s
entonces la vamos a dividir entre 10
tenemos 0.50 entre 10 es igual a punto
05 que es la desviación estándar de aquí
la cual podemos ver como 5% ahora lo que
quiero es un intervalo alrededor de mí y
media muestral donde yo esté totalmente
confiado dadas todas las estimaciones
que tenemos que hay un 95% de chance de
encontrar la verdadera media la que
estoy buscando la verdadera media entre
dos desviaciones estándar es lo repito
lo que estoy diciendo es que hay un 95
por ciento de probabilidad de que entre
estas dos desviaciones estándares ahí
entre esas dos está la verdadera media a
la que yo estoy buscando lo voy a
escribir o sea que hay un 95% de que la
verdadera media está entre ese intervalo
entonces lo que yo quiero es encontrar
un intervalo
yo esté razonablemente confiado y lo
digo de esta forma porque en realidad es
una estimación yo no sé que la
desviación estándar es exactamente 0.50
por eso hablo de una confianza razonable
entre comillas es decir quiero encontrar
un intervalo tal que yo esté
razonablemente confiada de que existe la
95 por ciento de probabilidad que en ese
intervalo la verdadera la verdadera
media poblacional entonces escribo la
verdadera
la verdadera media poblacional que es lo
mismo que la proporción de la población
que va a votar por el candidato ve o lo
que es lo mismo la proporción de las
personas o de la población que van a ser
un 1
ahora hay que recordar que muy muy es
igual a pp y que existe una un 95 por
ciento de probabilidad de que pe esté en
ese intervalo entonces que está en ese
intervalo
ahora pausa quiero quiero ponerle pausa
que a este vídeo ya llevo 14 minutos
entonces quiero que observes que
analices lo que hemos hecho hasta ahora
nótese obtuvimos la media muestral aquí
x barra es la media muestral obtuvimos
un estimado de la media muestral
no sabemos exactamente quién es la media
muestral ésta es una media de la muestra
no sabemos exactamente cuál es la media
muestral de esta distribución y tampoco
sabemos cuál es la desviación muestral
nuestra distribución muestral sin
embargo fuimos capaces de estimar la
mediante nuestra desviación muestral
estándar
basado en todo lo que hemos visto de
intervalos de confianza como podemos
encontrar un intervalo tal que se
aproxime mucho tanto como un 95 por
ciento donde p se encuentre en ese
intervalo piénsalo